well it's finally happened Dirty Harry's
gone Broadway which would be incredible
if it meant I could buy tickets to
something called the Magnum force
Follies yes June brings its usual
scourge of sci-fi tentpoles and event
television but it also brings Eastwood's
film adaptation of Jersey Boys a musical
about the four seasons
look musicals are great Rocky Horror
Picture Show Sweeney Todd Little Shop of
Horrors I even found spider-man turn off
the dark to be a revelation
though the Taymor de Bono ratio was way
off I just flat-out loved the form it's
like martial arts with melodious rhyming
dialogue in an orchestral backing Busby
Berkeley
Vincente Minnelli Stanley Donen Bob
Fosse and where might I ask is the movie
based on cats you know who could play
the cat's cats think of the social media
buzz but jukebox musicals oh they are an
arat illogical nightmare Mamma Mia Rock
of Ages oh you can sprained a plat phone
trying to build a coherent story around
a bunch of pre-existing songs I mean
have you seen the 1978 Sergeant Pepper
jukebox musical starring the Bee Gees
for some reason no good forget I ever
mentioned it seriously don't go looking
for it online you might find it and then
your soul will shatter it's like looking
into the face of an elder God with disco
the least bad kind of jukebox musical is
something like Jersey Boys or Ray or I
walk the line where the songs make sense
after all it's a life story of the
people who perform the songs but I
expect more from Clint Eastwood than a
straightforward biography that recreates
a bunch of old Frankie Valli hits the
man is not just an oscar-winning actor
and director he's an award-winning
composer and songwriter play misty for
me classic and who can forget
but suddenly my words read someone
else's
you should play a gravelly voice Greek
chorus in Jersey Boys we want to hear
all Flynn eyes croon original songs
about the rise and fall of the four
seasons okay Clint after that you can
get to work on Unforgiven the musical
the song deserves got nothing to do with
it will be a showstopper which Dirty
Harry movie would you like to see turned
into a musical let me know in the
comments and subscribe to the wired
Channel